how did the news get delivered to you
that you're going to be free and being
able to come back home
so i was lucky
to receive some letters from home of
course there's no news about me coming
home but i
i learned that how a lot of people were
working on our cases that you know
raising voices
you can see in the back here back a
banner that i
um kept it from 2009 it was from one of
visuals that people
wrote messages to us that stay strong so
that was a message that i received from
home
and north korean
government did not even tell us until we
come home that we're going to go home
they the day before we came home they
told us that you have a visitor
from the us
and very high officer teacher and then
i asked the guy who delivered the
message i asked him is there
a way to is this moving forward or is
this the way it tends to go backwards
and he said oh
i think it's moving forward so i knew
that was there something that
good things going on and uh they took
that was the first day
uh that um except the
except at the corridor he said that was
the first that i met with
laura and that we were able to talk
and then they sent us a hotel it was a
korean hotel and then they had us wait
in the room for
over an hour and i uh talked to laura
and who
do you think who visited us and i told
her if
she goes maybe jimmy carter or this is
you know it would be
anderson we told we talked about all the
names that we
we knew who's to associate with the
north korea we bill clinton wasn't
president bill clinton wasn't even on
the list
and and i told you i don't think i would
recognize jimmy carter if i had
and they finally told us that you're
gonna go to that room
and when we went to a room there were
some people with uh
not korean people with the earpiece and
then standing
around so we knew that okay somebody was
very important
here and there were two double doors
and they opened the double door there
was a president clinton standing with uh
his gray hair
had a big like the window that had the
light
backdrop on him and uh and he looked
like an
enter to me so he opened his arms and we
ran towards him
and he gave us a hug and he asked i
think well
we're doing okay physically doing okay
he told us that you know
[Music]
i can't promise anything at this moment
but
we if we go we'll be able to uh
be on the plane physically and we
told him like of course i'm not gonna
say no yeah yes yes
and we saw him meeting
north korean leader at the time kim jong
il
and on the news
and so kim jong-il kind of had a smile
on his face on those pictures
so we thought oh something's going on
something's
getting better it's getting better and
uh laura was excited and i was excited
at the same time too
we're still in the same room and i i
told her let's not open the champagne
batter yet
i so i kept praying and kept praying
until
about four in the morning they told us
pack our stuff
and then we went we were pardoned and we
went to the
airport get on the plane
what point did you fully feel free like
would did you feel free at that moment
when you were pardoned or when the plane
took off and when you were on the plane
were you on the plane with uh president
clinton or
you were on a separate plane no we were
on the
plane with the president clinton and his
team and
he had uh uh he he asked us
if we want to make phone call to home uh
to family
so we're sitting on the north korean
soil
and we i made the phone call to my
husband and i told him i came on the
plane with president clinton
he goes don't no no don't call me back
when you're in the air
so he did not want to open the champion
yet
until the plane takes off so i called
him back after plane takes off
and then i finally felt everything felt
so surreal you know you're a prisoner
in north korea for 140 days and next day
you are in a private chat with the
president clinton
and everything that was so surreal
when you land and you're getting off the
plane and you see uh the picture of your
daughter
hugging you in that moment what are you
what are you thinking are you do you
still remember it till today
can you go to that emotion until today
to know what it felt like to hold your
daughter again
yeah of course that was the moment that
makes me really emotional but the
happiest moment at the same time
um i
when i um
walked to her i thought
that she would recognize me right away i
didn't know how much the four months
would do to this four-year-old girl
and she looked very confused so i opened
my arms
and hannah can you give me a hug it's
mommy
and she gave me a hug and then that's uh
that's the moment that i felt like i
wanted this moment so badly
i wanted to hurt my baby so badly